dans les cuisines d'insertion de
mantes-la-jolie quatre personnes
s'exerce au métier d'agent de
restauration en situation de handicap
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée ou
jeunes âgés de moins de 26 ans
ils participent tous au parcours
d'insertion professionnelle
elles sont recrutées en cdd d'insertion
ça peut aller jusqu'à 24 mois et on les
accompagne tout au long de leur parcours
sur la montée en compétences et en
qualifications tout un travail en
parallèle sur la levée des freins à
l'emploi qui peuvent être d'ordre
administratif mobilité sortait logement
en cdd depuis août katia s'occupe
essentiellement de la légumerie un
endroit où elles lavent les fruits et
les légumes qui arrive du territoire un
changement radical pour elle qui
travaillait avant dans la restauration
rapide
je voulais connaître un peu autre chose
je voulais connaître notre production
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses pendant
déjà préparé en grande quantité entre
1500 et 2000 préparation sont distribués
dans le lycée franco allemand de buc et
le lycée international de saint germain
en laye à terme l'ambition et d'élargir
les capacités de production nous
considérons que bien nourrir les enfants
est une de nos missions donc vous avez
une unification tarifaire tous les
enfants du département désormais sont
traités à égalité sur les revenus des
parents et nous avons prévu dans cette
unification à travers la création de ces
midi des mesures aussi liées à
l'insertion des cuisines opérationnel et
pédagogiques pour former des personnes
en parcours d'insertion
à l'avenir ces midi et le département
souhaite créer de nouveaux postes en
insertion